my new book is everything I ever needed
to know about economics I learned from
online dating Irie entered the dating
market a couple of years ago and in the
intervening time where I'd been out of
the market to pretty dramatic things had
happened
one was the inter the rise of the
internet so when I went back to the
dating world it was completely different
than it had been before and the second
thing was I had become an economist and
so the combination of those two things
as I began to go into the online dating
world I couldn't help but think of it as
a market it is a market it's one of the
most interesting markets out there and
there's just so much economics going on
there so when we say thick markets we
mean markets with a lot of participants
so if you go to a mall with a lot of
different stores and a lot of different
goods and a lot of different shoppers
you're gonna find everybody's more
likely to get what they want then if you
go to a individual small store in the
middle of nowhere well by the same token
when you're thinking about what types of
how to how to approach the dating market
you want to go where the dates are and
so you want to think about okay I want
to get on the biggest websites or do I
want to sometimes think about getting on
a more specialized website that has
that's big maybe not as big but has more
of the types of people I want
so the idea behind signaling is we have
to find a way where when I say to you I
really want to go on a date with you you
believe me without thinking that I've
said this to a hundred other people and
so in there are a lot of mechanisms in
real life where we figured out ways to
do that in college applications we have
early decision and early action programs
where you signal to the college you're
my favorite choice and the way I've
proven that to you is I'm only allowed
to say it to one college
well the dating market would be one
thing that might enhance the dating
market and the job market I think this
would be a very good thing for
monster.com and the like is to have
people be able to send one or two
messages a month that say I really want
to date you and this is my only I really
want to date you message I'm allowed to
send this month there are a couple of
things that have already been done to
improve the online dating market in some
places one of them is a lot of websites
have not in the United States that I
know of but in foreign countries I know
of websites in China Britain and Korea
at least where this is true you have to
send in verification of certain things
that you say so when you claim a certain
income they verify your income when you
claim a certain height they verify your
height and so forth so that's one way to
improve this situation because many
dates are wasted on people who tell lies
that are quickly figured out
the empirical evidence that people lie
on their dating profiles is very strong
they don't tell big whoppers of a lie
because the minute you meet the person
you know it's a lie but men tend to
exaggerate their height in their income
women tend to report slightly lower ages
and weights I wouldn't tell you to lie
but you do have to keep in mind that a
lot of people out there are shading the
truth in their favor and so you have to
keep you have to remember that you don't
want to lie but a lot of the competition
is and a lot of the people you're likely
to meet are going to turn out to be
slightly different than then they've led
them led you to believe based on their
profiles
I like to believe a good understanding
of economics can help you a lot in many
different contexts it can make you a
better business person that's what I do
every day trying to teach MBAs about
economics to make them more efficient
and I think understanding economics can
help you in the online dating market
because it tells you what types of
markets to think about how to present
yourself a little bit but I I would not
argue that economics is the only thing
that's going to make you successful